yep it happened guys and the memes
aren't lit the twitter board has finally
sold to elon for a whopping 44 billion
dollars so as the dust settles i wanted
to make a quick video recapping the
timeline of events and more importantly
look at the changes that elon plans to
make in the social media platform that
we all love and hate at the same time so
strap in this is going to be quite a
ride a timeline of events if you haven't
been living under a rock for the last
month then you'd be aware that the
mercurial billionaire we all love on
this channel has been on a crusade to
acquire twitter then out of nowhere elon
purchased nine point two percent of
twitter shelling out around three
billion dollars of his own pocket the
next day parag agarwal the ceo of
twitter tweeted out that he had welcomed
elon to join the board of directors but
in a major reversal on the 10th of april
the twitter board rejected this idea no
one was sure what led to that decision
still i suspect it had something to do
with elon sending out a series of
unusual tweets and polls about the
company that painted it in a bad light
then a few days later on the 14th of
april elon surprised us again when he
tweeted out that he had offered to buy
100 of the platform this announcement
led to the twitter board to scramble
screaming a hostile takeover all this
brings us to the present and after a
week of negotiations it was announced
that twitter would sell to elon and he
will take the company private by the end
of 2022 but after hearing all this you
might wonder what is elon's plan for the
platform so i want to cut through all
the political and philosophical chatter
around free speech and just focus on the
new features you and i may be seeing on
twitter soon and no it doesn't involve a
new like button in the shape of a tesla
icon for people following elon on
twitter he has laid out a lot of
breadcrumbs for us to pick up over the
years broadly elon wishes to undertake
four major changes to make the platform
better so let's unpack them one by one
the edit button first and foremost is
the inclusion of an edit button you me
and the weeknd all want the edit button
for that little mistake that gives that
tweet a whole new meaning live instead
of love licked instead of locked and
duck instead of anyways currently the
way twitter is set up doesn't allow you
to edit your tweets once you have posted
them so twitter has been toying around
with the idea of including an edit
feature for a long time however its
implementation will come with a whole
host of challenges this seemingly simple
change to the product will require
careful thought imagine someone tweets
something shocking and later decides to
edit it to make it more palatable but
users would have already responded to
the initial tweet and the damage would
have already been caused a later reddit
would lead to more confusion now granted
that most users would probably not use
this feature for the wrong reasons but
what do you do about the bad apples
people who are specifically using
twitter for nefarious purposes how do
you code for honesty one obvious
solution is to create an edit log like
facebook that lets people see the
history of all the changes but scammers
have abused this feature to con people
and spread disinformation on facebook so
elon and the engineers at twitter have a
lot of careful thinking to do if this is
to be a success maybe they decide to use
an ai to track the context behind each
tweet and intervene if someone tries to
change it too much or limit the time a
user has to edit the tweet after hitting
send just like the undo feature of gmail
either way twitter will most likely test
this new edit feature among users of
twitter blue its paid subscription
service before rolling it out to the
general audience and thanks to
alessandro palozzi who is considered a
leaker in the big tech community we now
have a pretty good idea of how twitter's
edit button might work if you look at
alessandro's leaks twitter has already
decided to incorporate multiple sub
features like maintaining an edit log
only letting people edit their tweets a
limited number of times giving users
only 30 minutes to edit their tweets and
displaying an edited mark next to the
tweet opening up the twitter algorithm
the second most important change that
elon wishes to bring about is to open up
the twitter algorithm so that users know
how tweets get recommended to them
according to elon twitter is way too
important and influential in today's
world to keep functioning behind closed
doors and trust me i've seen the social
dilemma and i think he's right twitter
users should be able to see how the
platform works and maintains complete
transparency in its operations this
means that it will allow users to see
how their tweets rank how they get
distributed to other users and whether
some have been demoted or promoted by
the twitter algorithm leaving no room
for behind the scenes manipulation in
addition it will allow users to
understand the factors that may increase
or reduce the visibility of their tweets
and use that knowledge to grow their
influence on the platform elon has even
suggested that twitter post the entire
source code on github so that
independent developers can look for
errors and suggest changes i believe
this is his way of creating a free open
source developer community around
twitter that will constantly give inputs
and ideas to the company on how to make
the platform better however i'm not sure
how he wishes to implement all this
because despite the user suggestions the
control of the code will still be in the
hands of the twitter executives making
accepting and not accepting the
suggested changes somewhat arbitrary
furthermore the twitter algorithm is
just the tip of the iceberg the main
power of any social media platform lies
in the data side of things so many
experts have argued that even if the
source code is made public it will be
totally useless without the inserted
data which contains plenty of private
and personal information in an exciting
twist of events according to disclose tv
some twitter employees trolled elon's
idea by adding a public repository on
the company's github page they called it
the algorithm and quickly removed it
before the source code was locked again
this has opened up a whole can of worms
for elon which i'm sure he wants to do
without as the company's new owner
anyway suppose he manages to implement
this properly in that case it will still
be a significant step towards
decentralizing a social media platform
we as users hardly know anything about
any other social media platform's
back-end algos so it'll be nice to see
someone changing that status quo
authenticating all humans the third
thing on elon's list is authenticating
all human users he has commented that he
wants to increase trust on the platform
and authenticating all human users is
how he wants to go about it not a lot is
known about how he wishes to implement
this feature but one possible way would
be to extend twitter's verification
system denoted by the blue tick next to
a user's name currently this
verification is available only to a
small group of people who have to meet
twitter's stringent criteria but this
feature can be opened up to the rest of
the twitter community in addition those
who are willing to back up their profile
with proof of identity such as a
passport should have the option to do so
however there are some problems
associated with this as well first of
all it will definitely dilute the
importance of the blue tick that most
political commentators journalists and
celebrities covered secondly there are
major concerns regarding user privacy
since verification of this kind will
require access to sensitive personal
information now we are already used to
sharing our personal data with private
entities but there are many people these
days who fear for their data privacy and
would like to keep away from the
platform if this becomes a mandatory
thing furthermore there are plenty of
valid reasons why some users may choose
not to use their real names or give
their personal information suppose they
are dissidents from an authoritarian
regime or repressed employees looking to
whistleblow on their company's
malpractices what does twitter do then
suppose they allow verified and
non-verified profiles in that case they
will create a tiered system of accounts
which doesn't really solve the problem
entirely some have even suggested that
elon authenticates humans using nft
profile pictures and blockchain
technologies i'm not sure how that will
work exactly but we can be sure that it
will not be easy for elon to fix this
problem overnight removing all the spam
bots the fourth and final thing that
elon wishes for is to divert company
resources to root out all the scammers
and bots that have plagued twitter over
the years in various tweets and speeches
elon has always highlighted this problem
according to him it is the single most
annoying problem on twitter and he is
right i absolutely hate hate those bots
spambots have always existed on twitter
but these days there has been a rise of
crypto scammers on the platform they
seem to have a free reign on almost
every thread they flood user feeds to
lure unexpecting victims and a lot of
people have become prey to this twitter
already had a sophisticated way of
weeding out these spam bots by detecting
various automation patterns but the
scammers have always been a step ahead
of them they have become increasingly
slippery allowing them to pass through
twitter's filters undetected it is even
more challenging to detect manual fakes
which are human beings creating fake
profiles to spam and i think that
perhaps the point of authenticating all
humans would help in detecting fake
accounts according to one of elon's
latest tweets twitter engineers under
him will focus on taking care of
spambots and scammers once and for all
or die trying he believes that he can
use a combination of human
authentication and advanced ai to
eliminate these bots but the challenge
will be in differentiating between
automated bots and humans who act like
bots on twitter whichever way he chooses
to implement it if he successfully makes
twitter bot free i am sure that it will
be a safer experience for all users why
has elon's twitter acquisition drawn so
much commentary although twitter's
business model has barely changed in the
last 10 years and the platform has
failed to keep up with its competitors
like facebook or tick tock when it comes
to rolling out new and improved features
to its audiences yet it still somehow
manages to be synonymous with public
discourse it has become the de facto
medium for all our culture war debates
and it remains a pulpit from which
influential people all over the globe
communicate with the masses i believe
this is what attracts elon to it it is
less of a business decision for him and
more of an investment into humanity's
future he wants to see twitter become a
maximally trusted and broadly inclusive
platform in his own words which can
attract the brightest minds to freely
debate humanity's most challenging
problems in his mind he is working
towards a civilizational goal in a world
that is becoming increasingly regulated
and polarized whether he manages to
transform the platform into a
civilization-defining company like
spacex or tesla or whether it ends up
becoming a mere tool for himself and
others to continue influencing their
vast audiences without any interference
remains to be seen if you enjoyed this
video do give it a thumbs up and
subscribe to the channel if you haven't
already see you in the next one